When we talk about politics, there's inside
baseball, there's inside baseball topics that
only political pundits would be aware of and
then you've got like your bonafide serious
crises that affect everyone. Whether you pay
attention to politics or not. One of these
serious issues that impacts every single American
is the collapsing confidence in the American
president around the world. And it's important
to understand that agreeing with the president
on every issue is very different than simply
having the confidence that the president is
going to adhere to some basic minimum norms.
So for example, I disagreed with Barack Obama
on some political issues. I disagreed about
drone policy. I disagreed about his approach
to the genesis of what ultimately became Obamacare,
right? I disagreed with Barack Obama and on
different policy issues, but at no point did
I worry that Barack Obama's behavior and norm
breaking would cause a crisis of confidence
around the world in the u s presidency as
an institution in our country. That's what's
taking place right with Donald Trump. And
He seems to be trying to convince people of
the opposite. And I have the numbers to show
you. So with Donald Trump, very often the
truth is the opposite of what he says. And
in fact, this is a phenomenon known as projection.
Trump is projecting onto others the truth
about himself and his administration. So here's
an example. Lately Donald Trump has been insisting
that the Democrats are a laughing stock and
that the world is laughing at the u s because
of the Democrats. Here's an example clip of
Donald Trump saying this,
these people at clowns, the Democrats at clowns,
they're being left at all over the world.
And I watched this morning, I watched Dancy
Pelosi trying to get through that with the
performance that Robert Muller put on, where
I don't think he ever read the agreement or
the document and the document said no collusion.
They don't even talk about that. So there
was no crime.
The truth just happens to be the opposite.
And we have the numbers and the numbers are
really bad. Pew Research Center Study Data
is from 20 a 2001 to 2018 there is a lot of
data on the screen, but what you will see
is that confidence in the United States president
to do the right thing regarding foreign affairs
has plummeted under Donald Trump in almost
every country with the exception of Russia,
Russia compared to Barack Obama and George
W. Bush, Russia is the country that has increased
their confidence that the United States president
will do the right thing internationally under
Donald Trump. Every other country on this
list is experiencing a crisis of confidence
in the American presidency. Canada is minus
61 France is minus 70 Germany and the Netherlands
are minus 75 Sweden is minus 83 in their confidence
that the American president will do the right
thing. Japan minus 54 you can see the way
that this is going.
I don't have to read every single one for
you, and again, Russia, the one country on
the list that has more confidence in the American
presidency when Donald Trump is the president,
so this actually matters whether you're into
politics or not. This is a metric that relates
to everything from economics to culture to
simply maybe being an American that might
travel to some of these countries. Russia
and confidence in the U s president is up
under Trump. Everywhere else it is down and
anytime that Donald Trump tries to pull our
attention somewhere, in this case it's the
world is laughing at Democrats, you should
immediately be suspicious that the truth is
the opposite and in this case, it just so
happens to be you only have to look to every
single recent meeting of world leaders to
see them putting this into action. We have
a picture up on the screen now for our video
audience.
I forget which meeting or summit this is from,
but increasingly Donald Trump is in a literal
sense, not part of the conversation with world
leaders and in the more metaphorical sense,
the United States has increasingly not a participant
in many of the conversations that the world
is having about serious issues when it comes
to global alliances, when it comes to trade,
when it comes to climate change, for sure.
Donald Trump personally and the United States
as a country, it's just not even invited to
be part of the conversation and it is this
crisis of confidence that is underlying it
and that is behind it. If you don't care how
the u s does, then you don't need to worry
about this. If you live in the United States
as roughly 70% of our audience does, you have
a vested interest in how the United States
does. It affects you, it affects your family.
It affects how we are seen around the world
and this is not good. If you're not worried
about this, I want to hear from you, okay?
If you are an American who lives in the United
States currently and you don't deny the numbers,
right? I mean if you just don't believe the
numbers, okay, then you can bury your head
in the sand and people do that. If you believe
the numbers and you live in the United States
and you're not worried about the crisis of
confidence that the presidency is suffering
under Donald Trump, I want to hear from you
genuinely. I want to hear your explanation
as to why it's not something that worries
you.